I would have predicted you with okay now  right I wouldn't either  no but here you are here we are all  right I'll go along we're cool me to  know I had Katie on your show I had a  run when she played one cheap early on  when she first put out she came in she  was kid yeah she's a gun I was a big fan  of the song so I had her in there  beautiful job she's great  we talked you know who's gonna marry you  I wonder you can have a celebrity marry  you yeah you have to why because that's  the thing are Consuelos Kelly Ripa's  husband married me he's a nice guy I  think it's a nice guy Wow where did you  get married right here Manhattan was my  end I didn't I didn't know you back then  good luck with the wedding thanks man I  wouldn't be surprised if I get invited  I'm not gonna convert I'll just send you  the invite right the invite because  Howard Stern's Maris